this is Alex Edelman a great comedian
and more important a great Observer of
life and Nuance in our world you know
the show is about me going to this
meeting of white nationalists and queens
a very real takeaway from it is like how
do we talk to each other how do we talk
about each other what potential is there
to create change in those that we're
encountering all the time when I saw
your show I went through
something and then by the time I came
out of it I had a different point of
view of what I expected that was
brighter and bigger and inclusive to the
point where you could see Humanity in
the white supremacist everything that I
love everything that I love making
everything that I love doing tries very
hard to reconcile two things that
shouldn't be
reconciled like the humanity and a
terrible person